a lot of us cringed as I just said when
it came to maths at high school I still
remember my fourth form teacher I'm not
going to name him because he was so bad
I could never get engaged with mass and
within about three weeks I was out and I
was only 14 years old but a new age
method may actually have solve the
problem any whoo is the creator of
rutube a youtube channel that teaches
maths to even the most resistant
students like moi and what's more he
says that it makes it fun as well he has
tens of thousands of subscribers and
that number is rising really really fast
it he joins us now from Australia great
to be on the program Eddie what are you
doing differently than what my teacher
did in fourth form look mathematics
isn't easy for anyone and I include
myself in that category when I was at
school my favorite subjects were English
in history so I Clannad know that
mathematics even if it doesn't come
naturally to anyone we can come to an
understanding if we have the right
support and an engaging approach to
learning it it's something that everyone
can actually access ok so so so a brief
nutshell what does the woo Tube teach
the kids while they're so excited about
with YouTube well it's pretty funny
what's happened is that many years ago I
actually taught a student who was very
ill and because he couldn't make it to
school I thought look it's a bit rough
to just send you home and say look I'm
going to see you in a month after all of
your treatment at the hospital is done
come back after you've finished Chapter
five I thought what technology can help
us with this so it was literally just
for this one boy that I started to film
all of my lessons but from there it just
kind of spread I think the thing that
people have found is useful about it is
that number one it's accessible all the
time that you know which I know you guys
are talking before about people using
their phones kids are on it all the time
it's you know hundreds of times a day
that they're going to check it well why
not be able to put learning in their
hands but in addition to that I mean the
thing that I love which is in the
classroom is just making sure that I
engage kids with whatever it is that
connects them to mathematics every kid
it's something different some kids just
love solving puzzles some need some
practical application like where am I
going to use this in a trade other ones
just want to find some way where it
makes contact with their lives like in
sport there's so many bits of
mathematics
sport hiding in there in plain sight you
see that's interests me now this read
interests me does that mean you make it
realistic and fun and most of all you
make it practical because so often when
I was sitting in class I was thinking
how on earth is this ever going to
impact me in my life are you saying it's
about being realistic and how these
problems and problem solving a fixed
real life look I think mathematics is
everywhere and every kid needs something
a little bit different so for example I
mentioned sport before I've got lots of
boys who they'll come into my class and
they'll be really polite about it
because they know I love what I teach
they say look sir no offense I want you
to know I just don't do math and so I'll
just sort of take that to one side and
I'll say okay so what what do you enjoy
and often they'll say are soccer I love
soccer
you know it's live and breathe soccer
and I'll just start to sort of tease in
as I talk about sake geometry I mean
picture a soccer ball one of those you
know there's traditional black-and-white
soccer balls the pattern that makes a
soccer ball and the way the Pentagon's
and hexagons fit together is intensely
mathematical you kick a soccer ball it
makes a parabola through the air and
there isn't a single soccer fan I know
who can't spat out some statistics about
their favourite player their favorite
team they're doing math all the time
without realizing it so making sure that
kids understand yeah mathematics might
look abstract with the symbols of the
shapes but actually it really tells you
something about real life I think that's
important edu I love what you're doing
but your parents wished you'd been a
doctor or a lawyer and you could have
taken a job earning some big money do
you have any regrets that you haven't
done that it's quite funny because the
first time that I was a working
full-time in a school and I had one my
friends say to me oh how are you
enjoying your first few days and I said
I loved it and I said yeah we give you
six weeks before you could have a tired
cynical frustrated old man but actually
the more I've been teaching this is my
10th year the more I love what I do and
since there is a real purpose I mean I
think we need Australia and is
fantastic educators in our school who
are passionate for the difference they
can make for young people every day that
I come to work I can see the 30 kids in
front of me and the difference I can
make to their understanding their growth
in character I think I just love it